-Former President Donald Trump
recently called in
to a Christian talk show
and said this --
-So nobody has done more
for Christianity
or for evangelicals
or for religion itself
than I have.
[ Laughter ]
-Here to talk about it is one
of our writers, Amber Ruffin.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Hi!
Hi, Seth!
-Hey, Amber.
So, what do you think
about Trump saying
he's done more for religion
than anyone else?
-I think he's correct.
[ Laughter ]
-You don't
disagree with that statement?
-Why should I?
It's true.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-It is?
-It is.
-But how is that possible?
What has he done?
-What has Trump done
for religion?
[ Chuckle ]
Well...
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
He did this.
♪♪
He did that.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
He did this and this and this.
Don't you forget about that.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
-But those are all bad things.
-He didn't say he's done
good things for religion.
[ Laughter ]
He just said he did more
for religion
than anyone else
while he was president.
And he's right!
No president has done more
for religion.
More bad stuff, that is.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Why, he said this.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
He did that.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
He did this and this and this.
Don't you forget about that.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Wow.
That is a lot.
-It sure is, Seth.
-Do you have more?
-Me?!
[ Laughter ]
More?!
What do you think?
He also said this and this
[ Laughter ]
and this and this.
And this.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
You know he did this.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
But it was more like this.
[ Laughter and ohs ]
♪♪
♪ And... ♪
♪ Thi-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i... ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪ ...i-i-i-i-i-i-i... ♪
♪ ...i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i... ♪
♪ ...i-i-i-i-i-i-s ♪
♪♪
-Wow!
That's a lot.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
So, are you, um, done?
♪♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
Okay.
-He did this.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
He even did that.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
He did this.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Most of all, he did this.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
That's what he did!
-Amber Ruffin, everybody!
Check out
"The Amber Ruffin Show,"
streaming on Peacock,
with a new episode
streaming this Friday.
We'll be right back
with Senator Elizabeth Warren.